These storefronts are
American companies
that have had to leave Russia.
They now operate
under very similar branding
and sell very similar products.
But ultimately,
they're not Starbucks
or Dunkin' Donuts.
The mass exodus
of foreign brands
and life under sanctions
have changed things
for the Russian consumer.
A lot of people are
now looking to China
for goods they used to
get from the West.
In fact, it's so significant
that Xiaomi Corporation
became the number 1 bestseller
of smartphones in 2022,
dethroning Samsung.
Viktoriya and her sister
are a good example
of people looking to
alternative supply lines.
They're selling neoprene vests
after companies like
Billabong left the market.
They identified a company
in Guangdong province
and are now selling
to a growing cohort
of water sports fans in Russia.
The sanctions applied towards
Russia by many suppliers,
both European and American,
have created opportunities
for Russians to start
their own businesses.
It's more local and small
scale at the moment
but we plan to use this
opportunity and not let it go.
Some people compared
the current environment
to the Soviet Union
and its isolation,
but in reality it bears much
more resemblance to
Russia in the 1990s,
when the collapse of the
centralized communist system
led to gaping holes
in supply chains
and left it to ordinary people
to fill in the gaps.
An example from modern day Russia includes
a veto a listings website that's now
Avito,
a listings website that's now
full of people offering to bring
foreign branded goods
to Russia from abroad.
In another example, one
businessman is exporting gold
from Russia to
United Arab Emirates
in exchange for goods.
But not every sector
is open to opportunism.
In aviation, airlines are
having to ground planes
and cannibalize them for parts.
And used foreign cars
are selling for more
than when they were brand new.
And for the Kremlin
that's navigating a
declining economy,
Viktoriya's entrepreneurship
is encouraged.
In fact, they're calling
this new era
the mobilization economy.